have you wrapped your brain around the
fact that there are what 8 billion
people on this planet there is so much
success to go around there's so much
happiness there's a tremendous amount of
money to make there's a ton of people to
date and when you
focus on the fact that there is
limitless possibilities for you you're
not in competition with anybody in this
room and the louder you cheer for other
people the more you invite people in
the more you will be invited in and the
more cheering there will be for you
it is incredible when you can flip your
mind from being jealous and competitive
and small-minded like if she's getting
that it means i don't oh no no no no if
you see somebody getting something that
you want it's evidence
that you can have it too
you're just going to get it and have it
in your own way and so you want to make
it a habit to cheer for and celebrate
all the women everybody you see around
you because their success means you can
have it too and trust me
if you are a talented hard-working kind
person a company will make room for you
they will find another job doing that
same thing and so you focus on you you
focus on being the best you and i
promise you all the other people around
you that are having those things that
you want
that's evidence you can have it too i
like to think of other people as a light
on the path i'm walking down
they're shining a light
that helps me walk in the direction of
what i want hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that's
holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
get one percent better every single day
so how many of you struggle with a bit
of comparison and jealousy
yeah all your hands should go up that's
right because we all do right so you
want to know a cool thing about jealousy
jealousy is like the coolest emotion
because jealousy tells you what you want
i'm not talking about envy like i hate
her she doesn't deserve that
i'm talking about that like
i want to be doing that oh i went
you know you can relate to that feeling
right that like oh when's it gonna be my
turn oh i want that thing
so here's the cool thing about jealousy
you can't be jealous of somebody
unless you want the thing that they have
so it's personal
so personal
my daughter who is a singer-songwriter
that's what she's studying she's a
junior in college she's so jealous of
anybody that's on tour she's so jealous
of people that are doing the work and
putting out their music i am not jealous
about that at all
my voice is terrible like if i sing a
hymn in church people are like you need
to pipe down over there because you're
ruining this moment for me
i am not jealous of somebody who has a
penthouse in abu dhabi because i don't
want to live there
that is not what's meant for me
let me tell you what jealousy actually
is
jealousy is your deepest desires and
dreams blocked by your fear
jealousy is your deepest desires and
dreams blocked by your fear
your fear your insecurity your imposter
syndrome your past trauma all that
garbage it has put a lid
on what is meant for you
and so when you feel jealous of someone
or something or some opportunity and you
feel yourself putting the lid on and you
feel that negative energy coming on you
need to again use the five second rule
count backwards five four three two one
take control of the moment
and then flip it and go oh interesting
i'm not actually jealous
i'm inspired like that's my desire
that that person is evidence and here's
the other thing you all live in the
coolest moment in time
you can literally stalk people online
legally
you can learn from anybody
you know when i was your age if you
walked into a bookstore or a library and
you checked out a self-help book
whoa
that was embarrassing
personal development is like the coolest
thing in the world you can listen to
podcasts for free
you can literally research any subject
on the planet from neuroscience to
launching a business to how to monetize
and and make money on instagram to how
to install a shopify account and makes
it like you can research anything
you can follow anybody's footsteps
reverse engineer it and start walking
down the path
it is so cool
and so the only thing that's going to
limit you
in terms of you doing the work
to have everything that you want in your
life
is your fears
now i'm not in the land of toxic
positivity here because i know
that there is a lot of realities around
money and time and obligations that you
have to help out family or stuff you
have to deal with in terms of mental
health i totally understand that but i
want you to hear me loud and clear
that you can make anything happen
through your actions and your attitude
it may not take
a year
it might take ten years
but it's through action that everything
changes rule number two learn to say no
with gabby bernstein hi maria how are
you sweetheart i'm doing well how are
you gabby
i'm doing great i'm happy to be back
with you guys
this is my first time joining in on zoom
so
of course i get chosen
meant to be baby meant to be
um so i'm so glad i'm just thinking of
tina and
riley as well and i'm just wishing them
well so what's your dear gabby
sweetheart
i tend to give myself to the ones i love
as much as i can i i love helping people
i've noticed though that it's turned
into a pattern of
burning myself out at the expense of
others
especially my parents they're reaching
that age now that
i want to give back to them you know
they gave so much to me growing up and
now i'm i'm an adult and i can give back
to them
yet i'm finding myself being pulled in
that direction and in the direction of
my husband and the family we're trying
to grow so it's
a lot
so a lot of you giving giving giving and
not a lot of you receiving receiving
receiving is that correct
right i mean at this moment not a lot of
receiving i just i don't ever feel like
i
i should expect that from others i guess
okay let's go there let's go there okay
so my love
the story line i don't think i should
expect that from others
that over giving is my
special skill
over giving is what makes me good enough
feel good enough feel worthy enough i
see you shaking your head yes
and in that place of over giving what
you're doing is
overriding
your core need to be
seen and soothed and loved and cared for
by others
and often what happens when we go into
that pattern of over giving
we not only
burn out ourselves because we're just
exhausted from all the giving giving
giving
and we don't have the belief that we are
worthy of receiving but what is even
worse is that we don't allow others the
opportunity
to give to us
when you show up so much
the expectation and the dynamic is set
up that oh she's going to take care of
it she's going to show up she's the one
that's going to fix everything
and i want to honor you for your desire
to serve your parents at this later time
in their life they did it sounds like
they did a lot for you all of that's
beautiful all of that's admirable
but it can't be at your own expense it
can't you cannot be overriding your own
well-being we're seeing this a lot of
the belief system that i'm not good
enough unless i'm saving everybody else
now that belief system will just burn
you out and so as this relates to our
topic of do less and attract more
what i
want to point out is that every single
big issue that we face here on dear
gabby has a bigger root cause condition
right we all have these uh experiences
at a young age and in our childhood that
have established
the
the limiting belief systems of i'm not
good enough if i'm not
serving or
controlling or in the case of our first
guest tina i'm not good enough unless
i'm doing doing doing and perfect in her
perfection world and so when we carry
these beliefs into adulthood they become
the exact beliefs that open us up to the
possibility for healing because they
bring us to our knees they bring us to a
bottom they bring us to the moment of
saying i need a miracle this ain't
working anymore and hopefully they do
because if they don't then we just live
in a hamster wheel constantly stuck in
the behavioral pattern but if you're
listening to dear gabby
you know well enough that this is an old
pattern that you've been recreating in
the present and so
the the deeper work i'm always going to
come back to this the deeper work of
undoing the past and the history and the
stories of why you need to over give to
feel good enough has to be addressed in
a therapeutic setting has to be done in
a deeper deeper therapeutic work
whatever form that comes for you but
what we can address right now in this
moment is starting to create new
habitual adjustments to get just into
the practice
of trying to be more receptive because
you can do both simultaneously you can
do the deeper bigger healing work in
therapy and at the same time start to
adjust your behavioral patterns because
you have enough awareness you have
enough personal growth you have enough
support around you even being here and
part of the dear gabby community to
start to show up for yourself
right
okay
so i want just like with tina i said i
wanted her for counting 90 days doing
nothing to do less right i want you to
start my love to give yourself
permission at least once a day counting
days
to
say no
oh i see your face she just went uh like
your face literally said uh-oh
your face said uh-oh
what it what what comes up for you when
i say that
well i don't it's not necessarily an uh
oh as much as
it's
like time and i need to just surrender i
think i've
i've been in that space the last
probably two weeks where i
i've been praying for the signs and i
don't know if god's finally gonna throw
a shoe at me and say i've sent you so
many signs like just surrender woman
so i think that was the sigh of
okay i need some behavioral strategies
for moving to that next step because uh
the the knowledge is there and i'm
hearing the words and i'm nodding and
i'm like well yes
and now it's like okay step into it um
so uh that's why i'm going to a state of
amnesia when we're
in when we're in any form uh triggered
into the habitual pattern of the ways
that we avoid our feelings right so we
go into a temporary dissociated state
where we literally are like
forgetting all of the spiritual and
personal growth knowledge that we have
and we just dive right into uh okay i
gotta help everybody now and then you
feel hungover the next day from it and
you're like how did i get there again
and it is like any other addiction
helping and over serving is another form
of addiction once again and
we are when like i said over and over
this is a space where you're going to
want to use the support systems that the
universe can bring to you i want to pray
for you right now to be guided to the
right healers and therapists and support
systems to help you heal the root cause
condition
but what we can begin to do and have
some fun with and not overthink
is just start to play a game called the
no game
play the no game
and it's going to be super uncomfortable
and you're gonna mess it up and you're
gonna you're gonna be awkward and you're
gonna feel
so weird doing it
but
we can change patterns
through the repetition of a new behavior
and we can do that while we're
simultaneously healing the root cause of
the problem so
this is your gabby
homework
count to 90 days and then keep going
after 90
of once a day
saying no
no i will not be able to help you with
that no i'm not gonna cook dinner
tonight no i cannot drive to your house
mom and dad to do whatever you need me
to do no no no no no no no you sound
like my little toddler oliver no
no
no i want you to literally sound like a
toddler no no i'm just kidding but i i
do i do really want you to take this
seriously because you have to practice
your no and the thing that you also have
to hear from me is that sometimes no is
the kindest
word that's the kindest response
because when you're overriding and
overdoing you're actually becoming
resentful you're becoming resentful of
all the people that are taking and that
resentment is going to come out in your
energy it's going to come out in your
attitude and it's not actually helping
those people so you think you're helping
by saying yes yes yes but actually
you're harming because inside of you
it's just this battle of saying no
when the outside is yes yes yes and that
creates a big ball of resentment that
with that whether you realize it or not
is being picked up all around you rule
number three organize your life better
with brendan burchard you have to find
what feels good for you
you have to figure it out
my friend adrian who teaches uh you know
yoga with adrian someone i just love i
just one of the great original you know
big online yoga teachers just an amazing
amazing person her i think her whole
brand was like find what feels good i
love that and it's very common saying in
health circles but i feel like a lot of
people don't run in health circles and
so what feels good for you
like what feels good
for you
like genuinely feels good mentally
emotionally physically and spiritually
you need to journal about that
what feels good to me
in my health practices
so i'll give you some of mine because i
want to make these tactical as well
for me what feels good for me
personally and it's not the same for
everyone what feels good for me
as an example a calm
slow
morning
i'm i'm pretty dumb in the morning
i'm slow to rouse in the morning i like
to you know kind of shuffle around the
house you know get a tea or coffee
uh uh yeah i know you're like are you
drinking coffee now i'm like i do
usually half calf maybe mostly decaf but
once in a while i went on a trip to
france and they had that espresso and i
just oh my gosh it ruined me i think i
went 36 37 years of my life without any
coffee anyway now it's the flavor uh and
it'll sit down with the with my book
a little piece of paper in my journal
and just like a slow morning
a slow morning is great for my mental
health that's for me
right my wife is the opposite she's
incredible by like
by like 10 a.m she has done more than
most humans in a decade i don't know how
she does it shout out to niece like
like one of the most amazing
like she can she wakes up and a list of
things download into her brain
and she just starts going at him it's
unbelievable talk about a morning person
i i me
my mom the opposite my dad he boy he
could he was ready up and go to work
because he was in the military all his
life
biologically we all have different
rhythms don't we
right some of those are conditioned and
we create some are that's how we are i
think i conditioned my slow morning
because
i like it
what feels good to me is a slow
morning
how simple is that
how controllable is that even if there's
chaos and there's a lot going on i can
find my moments which we'll talk about i
can find my moments to recalibrate and
reset even if it's hectic and crazy
because there's people around the house
or something's going on
still
i got to make sure that that morning
finds those moments of calm and peace
and intention for myself otherwise
it can really frazzle out a lot of the
day so that feels good to me
also what feels good for me is sleep i i
we can't have a conversation without
this if you have never done hard work to
figure out exactly how you
can have your best night of sleep on a
recurring basis
there's almost nothing more we would
need to talk about than you doing that
alone
sleeping
seven to eight hours a night for all
humans all around the world is vital
people always say no no brendan you
understand i can do six hours a night
i'm like yes
you can
and you have no idea how much more
effective and happy you would be
with more
but i can get away with this or you
don't understand this or this thing's
going on or i just have the kids or i'm
like i not trust me i understand i've
been doing this and teaching this for 20
years i've had all the conversations
there's no surprise you're going to
throw at me about sleep
what happens though is people use the
excuses versus makes the plans
i need you to make the plans
i need to make the plans
very key did you make the plans
so what is your plan for having great
sleep
and sometimes it sucks i get it
it's like
you feel like you just can't even get a
break you know there's life there's
intensity there's things there's people
there's family there's all that you know
i get it
and
you got to figure that piece out for you
i love sleep it feels good to me so i
try to protect it
what else find find what feels good you
know what feels good for me
planning
planning if you look at my my growth day
my plan it's full it's filled out with
plans and deadlines and reminders if you
look at next to my computer there's all
these checklists written down like i
and by the way i don't naturally do that
i actually don't like planning i love
the mental and emotional effect
of planning
anyone follow that one
yeah you guys see right
that's the difference maker for me
i don't like the act of sitting down and
doing it's not like i find tons of joy
in organizing my life i just don't
i love the mental clarity
the peace
the
progress that comes from making plans
write down your goals write down your
deadlines
identify your projects know who you need
to reach out to know who you're waiting
on know what your priorities are of the
day
if you need any advice on this in growth
day
remember you can go to the learn section
you can smash the watch past events and
you can watch an entire month of
training on productivity
you can go to your courses and watch an
entire training on the habit of
productivity from the world's
number one you know i'm sorry the
world's you know largest research study
on high performance habits that high
performance habit builder course that
you have unlocked in the course section
of your app
just go to the learn section go to
courses and you can see high form's
habit builder there's a whole section
just on productivity and
that productivity isn't done just to get
ahead and to succeed it's because you
feel better when you organize your life
better
when you lead life and live life with
more intention
when you have a little bit more clarity
you feel better
strip away someone's clarity
their intention
their connection with what they need to
do today
and misery
sets in over time we just know it
with no connection to our intention and
our future
we feel less motivated
and good today
that's why the plan is so important for
me
what else feels good to me less carbs
you know i love to eat them
i don't like the feeling afterwards
i love to eat them
the feeling afterwards does not align
with my energetic vision
right so i would be a person who my
natural tendency would like give me all
the potato chips give me all the pizza
give me all the bad food 24 7.
but the effect of it doesn't align with
my energetic vision
and i know when i
do those things and i feel terrible the
next day
it's so out of alignment for what i want
energetically in my life
my self-respect goes down
i get down
and i'm less productive happy
does that make sense
very key to understand
very key to understand that's for me
again i'm showing you my things another
thing i know feels good for me because
people always ask
i'm like
massive amounts
of water and electrolytes every day
like i really believe most people are so
dehydrated they have no idea that most
headaches as an example are tied to
dehydration most people have no idea
that their physical stiffness and
inflammation happens because they're not
having enough water go through their
body a lot of people are so dehydrated
and they're shocked when you just like
drink some more water and like really
and they start doing they're like this
changed my life oh my god and now they
have like fancy little bottles all
around the house and they carry them
along with them you know
i think it's important
that most people realize how critical
hydration is
to their lives so i have to learn that
i also know that what feels good to me
is a body that's not inflamed
by terrible diet or things that i drink
or consume that increases inflammation
as inflammation goes up fatigue goes up
as inflammation goes up weight goes up
as inflammation goes up life expectancy
goes down
like you want to find one or two main
culprits of dis-ease in our health
physically inflammation a high
inflammation diet kills you sooner
so we have to figure out like okay we
have to study like what are the things
that inflame my body that's partially
knowing what you might be allergic to
right your food allergies as an example
but also just the basics of
understanding certain things you eat or
consume
tends to elevate your level of
inflammation and if you don't know what
those are see a dietitian a nutritionist
go read some books watch some videos on
youtube about anti-inflammation diets
and you'll see it completely changes
your life did for me
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four touch your genius
with sadguru there is something called
as a genius in a human being every human
being has it every human being touches
it at some moment of life
but the question is how often do you
touch it that's a question
you sparked once in your lifetime
that's not good enough you must be
sparking all the time isn't it
what is genius
the many ways to look at it one simplest
way to look at it is
when we say intelligence
we are always thinking logical thought
now
logical thought
will be meaningless probably in another
25 years
because your computer may be able to
explore all the permutations and
combinations of logical thought much
quicker and better than you can do so
touching the genius means there's
another dimension of
intelligence within you
what did you have for breakfast chicken
and salad
she ate a chicken
over the afternoon this chicken has
transformed itself into a human being
if you ask charles darwin
how long does it take for a chicken to
become a human being he would talk in
terms of millions of
years here he is
over the afternoon
he transforms a chicken into human being
so there is an intelligence here
there is a competence here
which is capable of what nature did over
a million years
like that over the afternoon
only thing is this is an unconscious
unconscious state of intelligence
whatever is unconscious if the necessary
striving is there you can make it into
your conscious process in your conscious
process
if this intelligence even a drop of this
intelligence is available to you
suddenly life will spark like it's a
magic
what everybody's logs for
you can just simply do it
now when i say intelligence always
people would think this
if you say intelligence and ask them to
show in sign language they'll also
always say this isn't it they'll not say
this or this or this or this
but one cell in your body
is doing
more activity than your brain could ever
do
one molecule of dna is doing so many
millions of functions in a minute that
you can never ever figure it out yes or
no rule number five read books with jay
shetty so many of you have been asking
me jay how do you read so many books how
do you get through them what's your
strategy what's your approach do you
even sleep the answer to all those
questions is in this video now how many
of you have a stack of books that's
taller than you that you really want to
read this year this month this week and
it just keeps growing and you keep
looking at a schedule and thinking i've
got less time this week than i had last
week and maybe you're thinking i don't
even know where to start reading is
super important i found it really
fulfilling in my life and really useful
and insightful as well i want to share
with you what some of the most
successful people in the world think
about books warren buffett says that he
spends five to six hours a day reading
five newspapers bill gates reads about
50 books a year mainly business health
engineering diseases mark zuckerberg
says that he reads books to learn and
educate himself about different cultures
and backgrounds oprah calls reading her
personal path to freedom mark cuban says
that he reads to learn about new
industries now this is gonna tell me how
old you are if you remember the
britannica encyclopedia elon musk said
that he read that by the time he was
nine in total and this is my favorite
one phil knight the ceo of nike said
that he kept his library so sacred that
when people entered it they had to take
off their shoes and bow down so there's
plenty of good reasons why you should
read but you really need to know your
own that's my number one tip you need to
know why you're going to read a book is
it because you want to be entertained
and have an escape is it because you
want to learn new information and grow
is it because you want to find new ideas
about how to improve your life the
closer you get clarity on your vision
for why you're reading a book the more
likely you're going to be a successful
reader now i'm not going to be teaching
you a new technique that's going to take
you a year to learn before you even
start reading or something that you need
to practice i'm gonna share really
practical simple tips on how to read
more
faster better so the first thing i do
before i start reading a book is i find
the ted talk i find the youtube video
that's going to tell me all about that
person's big idea what i'm trying to do
here is grasp the concept of the book as
quick as possible it allows me to
understand the essential principles the
underlying thought behind the book from
the author without having to invest a
week or a month or however long it takes
to actually finish a book for you or
maybe never so being able to watch that
ted talk what's that youtube video
allows you to figure out whether you
even feel that that topic is compelling
whether you feel attracted to that
subject or whether you feel you
understood it from the talk and might
not even need to read the book basically
my point is that talk should let you
know whether that book is worth reading
for you it should inspire you to want to
go and order it straight away if it
doesn't it's probably a good idea to
skip no i'm not gonna read this
and you don't lose anything you've just
watched a 15-minute talk and learned
loads of new stuff so i'm going to talk
you through a book that i read last year
it's called the organized mind this
could be any book i'm just using this as
an example because it has some
highlights in it the first thing i do
when i get a book after i've watched the
youtube video or a ted talk i highlight
the sections that i really find
interesting most books today
self-development books personal growth
books all split up into parts here you
can see part one part two etc etc and
the first thing i do is i highlight the
sections in that book that stick out to
me straight away it's like going to a
menu and saying i really like the sound
of that i'd love to taste it i really
like the sound of that that's what i
want to learn about and that requires
you to be really conscious of what
you're willing to gain from the book so
as you can see here what i've
highlighted in part one is too much
information too many decisions i want to
improve my decision making so i've
highlighted that in part two i've
highlighted organizing our social world
i'm super interested about how humans
connect and so i've also circled that
bit here i'm making a selection of the
parts of the book that i want to read i
always recommend reading chapter one the
author has put so much energy into that
chapter that you definitely shouldn't
miss it but after that make sure you're
highlighting the spaces that you're
really gonna dive into i recommend
highlighting one to two chapters from
each part now you may be thinking do i
start from the introduction some
introductions actually teach you how to
read the book if an author has done that
that's incredible make sure you read
that introduction apart from that you
can start at chapter one and then make
your way through let's do this so now
you've circled the chapters of interest
you can dive straight into them and as
you get into them i'm going to give you
a few quick tips on how you can make
that process faster and more useful now
if you're someone who loves audiobooks
there's these really cool apps that
actually speed up how quick you can hear
now if you're a reader like me there's a
way of doing that too when you're
reading as simple as it sounds it works
you can use your finger as a guide the
more you speed up your finger times one
times two times three the quicker you'll
be able to read it's the same thing all
your book apps are using right now you
listen at speed one and then move to
speed two and move to speed 3 you're
simply using your finger as the ability
to start reading faster it actually does
work the other thing you can do is focus
on the most important words in a
sentence we've all seen those examples
where you could actually read words and
paragraphs where all the letters and all
the words are jumbled up because our
brain is able to process the bigger
picture quicker what i recommend is
focus in on the more stronger words in a
sentence hence if a sentence has 12
words you can read the most important
four to six words and still extrapolate
the same meaning even inside a chapter
you can skip to subheadings and
divisions that you find fascinating we
have this fixation on reading every word
finishing every book and finishing every
page the reality is most of us never let
that happen the tips i'm giving you are
gonna help you read a book within two
hours or a day and help you decide
whether you want to read the book cover
to cover now imagine if you spent a
month or two months reading a book and
afterwards for well what did i gain from
that what did i learn from that if
anything what if you read it in two
hours and then had the opportunity to
decide to read the whole thing i
guarantee you when you do it in this way
you'll be able to read books that you
really really value another way to speed
up the reading process is read the first
three lines and last three lines of
paragraphs that you think you might be
interested in if you're not sure when
you do that you'll be able to quickly
contextualize whether that paragraph has
insights that you really want to know
authors place a lot of emphasis in
starting and ending paragraphs with key
information you'll be able to grab it
and decide if you want to read the rest
the interesting thing is when we read
even though it feels like we're flowing
across the words it's not true our eyes
are actually doing a stop start motion
and when i stop we're able to grab
information and when they start we move
to the next so that loses a bit of time
now when you're trying to look at the
most important words you're able to
grasp 90 of the meaning which is looking
at 30 of the words it also stops your
eyes from having to constantly do a stop
start motion trying to make it flow when
actually you're jumping to the most
important words in the sentence try it
out with three or five sentences and see
if it works for you now not all these
tools are going to work for you straight
away some of the more simple ones you
can put into practice right away i also
make sure that after a chapter i write
down what i call the 3s formula i write
down a story that really inspired me or
moved me i write down a statistic that i
thought blew my mind and the third thing
i do is i make a note of something i
want to share with someone else that's a
great way of getting more out of a book
now if you're not inspired by a book
drop it finishing a book is nowhere near
as important as actually learning from
it and gaining from it our success
metrics for reading books is how many
we've finished versus how much we've
actually learned so try out whichever of
these tips that work for you make sure
you start off by watching that ted talk
watching that youtube video to grab the
essence of the book the second thing you
want to do is highlight the key chapters
and areas that you really want to dive
into remember it's just like going
shopping you don't need to go through
every aisle to get what you want
remember you can grab as much
information as you need just from the
first three lines and the last three
lines of every paragraph to decipher
whether it's relevant to what you're
reading for and remember when you're
reading if something's not inspiring you
it's not motivating you you're not
learning from it don't drag yourself
through it find the next book and get
working rule number six set goals with
lisa billy how do i set my goals then
actually keep the motivation to follow
through
all right i love this question because
it's actually a two-parter number one
goal setting number two motivation
they are completely different and so we
think that if we've set a goal that
we're instinctually going to have the
motivation in order to keep them because
when we wake up in the morning let's say
we have like this new drive he's like oh
my god i want to do a youtube show let's
just do that nice and easy women of
impact i want to do a youtube show i'm
so excited i've set the goal i want to
hit 100 000 followers i'm going to do
that in a year amazing i've got the idea
i've got the strategy i'm on fire
and then three months later
she's hitting the fan i can't freaking
get guests on equipment is failing
the goal isn't going to help keep me
going so i actually see them as two
separate entities number one setting the
goal that means where do i want to be in
what amount of time that's how i do goal
setting so let's say for instance in
five years this is actually true in five
years i want to be able to affect a 14
year old girl that feels insecure about
herself
okay that's a very clear very articulate
mission of who i want to impact and how
i want to impact them
so now i go that's a very clear goal
okay but that's five years
try and keep motivation just by
repeating that goal in your head time
and time again for five years you're not
going to be able to do it why because
when you feel like [ __ ] about yourself
guys when shame comes in when guilt
comes in when all these emotions come in
that are i hate to say inevitable when
you're doing a journey when you're
trying to achieve something these are
all the things that may rear their ugly
heads so the question is how the hell do
i make sure those things do not keep me
from my goal because you've already set
the goal that has nothing to do with the
motivation that's going to get you there
so separate them now you've set your
goal okay i want to achieve this by this
state
now is what is the motivation i'm going
to use as a tool
on the days that i don't feel like i
actually want to achieve my goal because
it's going to happen it doesn't matter
how many times guys i tell myself that
i'm going to affect this 14 year old
girl it doesn't matter how many times i
repeat that to myself
when she hits a fan and i just for [ __ ]
about myself that reminder of what my
goal is doesn't freaking help it doesn't
snap me out of this
negative downward spiral that i might go
into no matter how much i really want
the goal so when it comes to feeling
motivated day to day what i do is i say
how do i collectively create a toolbox
so that when those days come that i
don't actually want to achieve my goal
because i just feel shy about myself
what are the things i'm going to use
okay motivation number one people say it
so i don't want it to be freaking cliche
or cheesy but it's true
have a freaking mission have your why
so my goal is to impact 14 year olds but
how do i emotionally connect to it
because it's very different from saying
i have a goal to emotionally connecting
and pulling me out of these holes when i
have it so i go back to what is a 14
year old
female having them think in a certain
way important to me because i remember
what it was like i remember guys what it
was like to be 14 and going in my mum's
room tearing up photos of myself because
i freaking hated my nose
being 14 and feeling shitty about myself
when i had these big dreams and everyone
told me that i had no right to dream
like that
all these things the little leaves are
inside me the things that i've had to
overcome
i go back to and i use it as my biggest
motivation so that on the days that i'm
not feeling good about myself i have my
why i go back to emotionally connecting
with my why so what i want you guys to
do right now is take what goal you have
and then connect emotionally to the why
what is going to pull you up and out of
bed on those days that you really really
do feel shitty about yourself
i can really get behind that i can
really say all right lisa are you going
to let your negative mind get in the way
and demotivate you or are you going to
freaking attach yourself to that 14 year
old that doesn't feel great about
herself so that becomes now a motivation
tool for me to go back to all right bear
with me that's just one tool it's like
the hammer now we want the wrench
and just in case it calls for a
different skill set
so what i then go to is music like music
really does allow me to feel a certain
way about something so anytime i'm not
feeling motivated any time i just feel
like i want to freaking sit on the couch
and lick my wounds over how badly i feel
about myself or oh my god lisa you're
not there yet on your goal and who the
hell do you think you are and can you
believe it's taking you this long to get
to your goal
all of these negative things that get to
me is what gets in the way of me
achieving the goal
i go to how do i influence myself on the
opposite way so once this starts to
spiral i go to freaking music
i play a song that gets me so freaking
amped and jammed and if i'm not feeling
it guys i literally will start to
wiggle like i'll actually start to sing
along i'll start to dance it's like i'm
a survivor right like just
belt it out put your arms like put your
body behind it that is another way of a
tool of how i get myself motivated so
another thing is we've all heard about
affirmations
but
there is a but you cannot just freaking
rely on saying an affirmation and
repeating it and then expecting it to
actually be so
no like i think that that's where we go
wrong with affirmations i think that's
where we go wrong with quotes and
motivation motivational tools like that
is that we just expect it to land but
you've got to freaking do the work right
it's like it's in front of you but
you're the one that has to actually
process that has to remind yourself of
what the affirmation means to you and
why on earth you're freaking saying it
in the first place so let me just give
you an affirmation that i use a lot when
i was starting to go on this journey
this too
shall pass
this too shall pass now
it's been used a lot but it's so
freaking powerful it's so freaking
powerful because it again everything
guys everything i ever talk about
whether it's goal setting whether it's
relationships everything i talk about
always comes back to how i feel about
myself like that's it like whether i
want to be a ceo of a company or whether
i want to be an amazing wife or whether
i want to be a good friend or whether i
want to get over my self-sabotage
it all comes back to that remember one
time where you fit social about yourself
you got it
you're holding on to it right now okay
great now how do you feel about it
you're like yeah it kind of steals
things but
it never is like it was on that first
date or when you first felt like that
and that's exactly how i feel about
saying this too shall pass it's like
while the feeling right now feels so
real it feels like i'm gonna feel like
this forever
the truth is is that you don't and this
is just one little signal and a reminder
that in that moment that you think oh my
god everything's falling apart and my
goals are uh gone to sh and who the hell
do i think i am going after my goals in
the first place it's just a little
disruptor that reminds me this too shall
pass
so guys those are some actual tactical
tips and takeaways that you can
immediately do
in order to push yourself to be
motivated to go and crush your freaking
goals
even when especially when you don't feel
motivated to do it rule number seven
have self-discipline with john astrad
when you're in a constant state
of review tweak adjust behave review
tweak adjust behave
that is a self-discipline
action and habit
that will lead you to achieve every one
of your health wealth relationships
career business charitable
every goal you have today i was thinking
about something
that i talked about on our last q a
session that lit up a lot of people's
minds and i think your emotions it was
around self-discipline
or self-discipline i said that
every one of us is 100 percent
self-disciplined already to our current
thought patterns emotional patterns and
behavioral patterns which obviously are
responsible for our results so
my question for you today is this
do you have the right disciplines
do you have the right disciplines to set
goals create plans and achieve them do
you have the right disciplines to prime
your brain
with your vision your goals and your
plans for the day every day do you have
the right discipline to review
your day at the end of the day to see
what did you do well what could be
tweaked so that tomorrow is even better
do you take time on sunday nights for
maybe 30 or 40 minutes to plan your week
so that you're not reacting to stuff but
you're planned you're organized you're
in action that's deliberate versus
reactive that's another discipline
do you take time every month to review
your month do you take time every
quarter to review your quarter do you
take time at the end of each year to
review the whole year and then to plan
your vision for the next year your goals
for the next year now
these little disciplines
are what i call keystone disciplines or
keystone
behaviors and habits that set you up for
success and so
i like to consistently ask myself
do i have the right keystone habits the
the big things you know that swing the
little hinges that swing the big doors
so a couple things i can tell you that
really work for me
is taking the time to think to plan
to
review my results
and in a state of no blaming myself no
shaming myself no feeling guilty no
justifying no wishing i wish it was
different or better or this or that just
in a pure state of awareness
i tweak and adjust and tweak and adjust
and tweak and adjust and tweak and
adjust
and here's what happens what you'll
discover is you're gonna be on course a
lot of the time
you're gonna be off course some of the
time
but when you take the time to recognize
if your thoughts are aligned with your
vision and your goals are your emotions
your your things that cause you to take
action and not align with your vision
and goals are the behaviors that you're
taking aligned with achieving those
goals now
when you're in a constant state
of review tweak adjust behave review
tweak adjust behave
that is a self-discipline
action and habit
that will lead you to achieve every one
of your health wealth relationships
career business charitable
every goal you have
the how to achieve the goal
is the easiest part getting yourself to
take the inspired action because you
have a big reason why you must
is really what you need to work on
because we all are going to have
challenges we're going to have failures
we're going to have days we feel like on
top of the world and other days we feel
like oh man i just don't even feel like
getting out of bed that's okay that's
normal that's called being human
but if you have the self-discipline to
get up and do a little bit to get up and
adjust and tweak
then you win the game more than you lose
the game uh think about
athletics for just a moment
to make it into the hall of fame for
exactly for example in baseball
you will
not hit
three out of ten balls
you will not hit him you will not get on
base that means you're failing so to
speak seven out of ten times but to make
it to the hall of fame the best of the
best all you need to do is hit get on
base three times so a lot of people have
a misunderstanding of success and that
is that you succeed every single minute
every single hour every single day and
that's not just not true
right uh the most successful people in
the world are consistently taking action
making sure that it's the right action
if it's not they adjust so
have the self-discipline
to
not blame shame justify or make yourself
feel guilty have the self-discipline to
create the plans take inspired action
manage your thoughts get into the right
state the physiology the feelings that
you need in order to achieve your goals
dreams take inspired action daily and
don't focus on perfection focus on a
little bit of progress every single day
number eight the last one before some
very special bonus clips is have a
mantra with dean graziosi i want you to
have a mantra
or an incantation it is your battle cry
now you don't have to figure it out now
but i would love for you to figure this
out
and i wrote down some simple ones
because
in
i would say
i told you i went broke
and it was probably 20 years ago
that i made a big shift in my life and i
went from being in the collision
business and the auto sales business and
apartments and real estate into the
self-education industry what i'm in now
and in that transition it was difficult
it was before the internet so i had to
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
for an infomercial i had to put product
in a warehouse it can't it's not like
today's world where we're all connected
online look what we're doing right now
those things didn't exist you want to do
a live event you had to spend the money
get an event you want to sell a course
you had to create a 200 000 infomercial
and buy media and all this stuff and man
i was burning up all the money i had and
it was just in a tough spot and then the
money i did have i had an accountant at
the time guy was 55 years old wow the
same age i'm almost now
never gambled a day in his life the guy
started gambling lost all his wife's
money went into my account to borrow
money to go gamble to get it back and
without knowing he burned up all the
money i had so now we hit a little
hiccup i go to the reserve money it's
all gone
and he hadn't paid bills for a couple
months a couple months like i just
happened to meet a guy at 55 who things
went sideways in his life um
i remember like there's no way i'd get
through this and i started telling
myself really shitty stories and i
remember feeling like what am i gonna do
and i'm gonna look like a failure and
everybody who told me i was crazy for
going in the self-education industry was
right and all these kind of things man
thank god for tony robbins thank god for
courses and getting in my mindset in the
right place and i remember i going
through all these processes i'm sharing
with you today
but one thing that really helped me is i
remember taking a walk and i got this
mantra in my head
and if i said if i can get through this
i can get through anything
and i remember excuse my language i only
swore once today i met my mantra was if
i can get through this
i can get through anything i'll leave
the s word out for the rest of it but
that's what i was saying to myself and i
remember just walking every day the gym
was like two miles from my house and i'd
walk to the gym and as crazy as this
sounds i remember thinking if i can get
through this i can get you anything if i
can get through this i can get through
anything and i said it over and over
like literally i'm walking down the
street and i remember cars passing me i
had earbuds in and i'm just repeating
this probably people probably thought i
absolutely lost my mind but i remember
thinking if i can get through this i can
get through anything and i just said it
over and over
i would love for you to come up with a
mantra
for this year maybe it's if not now when
if not me who
if not this what
if not now when
if not me who
if not this what
say it when you're alone say it to
yourself say it out loud go take a walk
but when you say it to the world it
comes back and it gives you this
visceral feeling that it's hard to
explain
this is my year
because
i'm going to be the man or the woman god
meant me to be
i'm going to this is the year i tap into
my full potential this is the year i
make no excuses
i don't know what yours is but i'm going
to encourage you to find a simple one
that when you're having those tough days
you go back to your why
you let your own why sink into your
heart that emotion
and then you repeat your mantra get
yourself back on track let me honestly
right now if i was going to judge your
state if a state if zero is lethargic
tired defeated i can't do this life
sucks and 10 is i got this i'm doing it
i feel it right now your state on a one
to ten where are you right now
these are i want to get you back to this
state because this is the state where
anything is possible this is the state
where you go i got this hand the
problems over to me you can't handle it
i got it this is the state we want to
live in so what are the things we can
what can we do to get us back in this
state when we're having a tough day
right
that's what we have to take so come back
over here so if we know where we are
with honesty
we know where we want to go
pretending it's a year from now it was
the best year of our life
we write it down like crazy
that's where we want to go if we know
where we are and we know we want to go
we have this gap that we have to fill
before we get the capabilities to fill
the gap
what do we need to do
we need to get into our hearts
we need to get into our emotion and we
need to create a why so deep
you know one of my students said once if
your why doesn't make you cry you didn't
go deep enough
and i'm not trying to say that but you
need a why that when you think about you
either get tears or goosebumps and if
you're not there you got to go through
the process you got to go through the i
went through it quick today but you got
to go through the real process of the
seven levels deep so you're so in line
with it so you're so connected to it
that when you're having a tough day when
stuff goes sideways because it will when
people don't believe in you because they
won't when every sign points that it's
not going to work that you're not going
to accomplishment accomplish it you need
to go back to this why and go i don't
care
listen you can't look at success through
odds you don't have the odds of being
happy healthy wealthy who cares about
odds you throw the odds out you have a
compelling enough why
nothing can stop you
so if you know where you are
and you know where you are want to go
and you know there's a gap you would
fill it with an emotion and then come up
with your yearly mantra your incantation
for the year you know it could be simple
if not now when
i want to be the woman god designed me
to be and this is my year just come up
with something no one has to know you
don't have to tell anyone else you're
having a tough day go take a walk and
say it to yourself i'm telling you the
more you say it the louder you say it
the more you put it out to the universe
you feel it in your body and you become
alive and that's what we need to fight
this good fight especially in a time
where things are a little crazy in the
outside world so if you know where you
are and you know where you want to go
you attach an emotion you get your
mantra the last piece
that's good mike the last piece
is how are you going to get there
how are you going to get there
right let's go back to the whiteboard
for a second
this is the this is the gap right and we
just need the pieces
to fill the void so as you're setting
goals if you want to make them a reality
right we we had the vision it was a year
from now it's the best year of our life
that's our goals we got an emotion
attached to it that's why i want to do
it
now how am i going to get there
that's where you need to decide what's
missing
if it's in business so many of you are
with with us in project next go back
into the course
get a coach get a mentor
right go back through it set goals that
stick look at my goals every day some of
you need the accelerated success formula
that's the gap to make sure you have the
right mindset that becomes bulletproof
maybe you need to get a mentor maybe you
need to work with somebody maybe you
need to get a gym membership maybe you
need a love coach maybe you need to go
counseling maybe you need someone to
help you figure out how to do meals
maybe you got to find a course to get
better at the meals that you make or get
a course to find your soul again i don't
know what capabilities you need but this
is the how
because listen
your best thinking got you here
your best capabilities got you here
that's not a bad thing
my unfair advantage is that i've bought
i've spent over a million dollars on
courses and masterminds and workshops
either attending them or creating them
in my life when i want to learn
something and this is the evolution i
want to share with you guys today i set
it up earlier but this is the part
that's really important when i want when
i have a gap in my life i told you the
gap in my relationship i told you my gap
in a business my gap in health when i
want to get from here to here
the first thing that comes to mind is
how and i want to get the capabilities
hear me number the most costly advice in
the world is learning from someone
that's not qualified to teach you bad
advice is the most costly advice so you
want to learn the how
and the capabilities from someone who's
already done it
but this has evolved in my head
see when i think of how to go from here
to here and i attach my emotion i've
evolved that to who
here come back over here
think about that
who
has already done it who has lost the
weight who has fixed the relationship
who
has launched courses online it knows how
to do it who has the mindset strategy so
i don't get lost in 2022. who has the
mindset strategy where i could stay
anchored stay in this state build my
confidence and become unstoppable feed
the inner hero not feed the inner
villain who has done that and when i
look through the lens of who it takes
away the anxiety i just want to find
who's already been there gain their
capabilities and then take uncomfortable
action
so today as we've taken this whole
journey together what i want to share
with you is when you know where you are
with honesty
when you know where you want to go
you have a compelling future
and you should stare at that every day
and then you must do something most
people don't you got to get into your
heart
and you got to attach an emotion to it
on why you want it
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not
that
one sentence
is at the core of how i've been able to
stay
so consistent to keep making content to
not give up to not get too discouraged
and to get back up every single time and
keep
going because i focus on who i am
serving instead of who i'm not
i just recently spoke at brendon
burchard's influencer summit and
i shared my graphic of how i've grown
over the years on my channel every time
i show that graph they always ask me how
did you keep going
in in the first five years when you had
no subscribers when you had no comments
how did you keep going
and how did you make so many videos how
did you not burn out how have you made
12 000 videos over 12 years how how do
you keep doing it and i don't think i'm
superhuman i don't think i'm i'm
extra special uh i think i had actually
more problems than most i'm i'm shy i'm
introverted i was afraid of the camera i
felt like only
egotistical people put themselves on
camera and told their story
i had lots of limiting beliefs and
struggles
in getting
my channel and just belief in myself
to put anything out there i hated my
first 350 videos i couldn't watch
anything back totally embarrassed by
everything i made
uh and it was 750 videos before i
inspired myself before i finally liked
one of my own videos like you know what
i'm starting to get decent at this that
was a good video 750 videos in before i
did that so how how how do you keep
going how does that make any sense
because i always focus on who i was
serving instead of who i wasn't
most of us just focus on who we're not
serving think about your growth think
about if you've made any kind of content
you know at the beginning you you get
nothing
right there's no reaction there's no
comments and then maybe you get one
comment and then maybe get five comments
maybe you get 10 likes or maybe you get
however many views on your videos right
you got 100 views on your video now
that's kind of the standard now if you
get 20 views again on a video that that
doesn't feel so good right or if you get
a thousand views on a video or 10
thousand views on there a hundred
thousand views on a video i remember the
first time i got a hundred thousand
views on a video it's like wow
i've made it
[Laughter]
and then it's easy to feel like oh the
next video got
ten percent of that and you feel like oh
i i suck it's not working
right
instead of focusing on that because
that's a losing game
focus on who you are helping and assume
that it is serving people
i've always felt i think some kind of
responsibility or
just gratitude that anybody would care
about what i had to say and that you
were spending your time with me
i remember my first speaking gig
was at the ymca in canada was at the
ymca and three people showed up
you know three people showed up and i i
just did my best to give a great
experience to those three people
and then i kept doing it and and the
next time we had four and then we had
seven then we had 12 and then we had 15
and then we had 20 and then we outgrew
the space and so then
i went to the boardroom of a bank uh
royal bank of canada and took over their
boardroom at night for entrepreneurs who
were free events i was putting on just
to help entrepreneurs i had no business
model or pitch just serving
and then we got too big for the royal
bank so then we went to indigo which was
a bookstore it's like a barnes and
nobles of canada
we had you know people coming out and
then more and more and more every every
two weeks i did it again and more people
came and at the at the height
we had the second most number of people
to ever show up at
uh at the bookstore
number one was sting when he launched
the musician sting when he launched his
book he came when he did a little
concert and that was the number one
event in terms of number of people that
came out and the second one was my
little entrepreneur
speeches
[Laughter]
it's crazy
when you focus on who you are serving
instead of who you're not it does a
couple of things okay
number one it makes you feel so much
better about what you're doing
it makes you feel so much better that
what you're doing matters right we all
want to feel like what we do matters and
if you're used to a thousand views on a
video and then you get 100 views on the
next one you feel like you don't matter
right you feel like you're losing your
value because it didn't reach as many
people don't think like that 100 people
saw it
be thankful be grateful for the 100
people doesn't mean that you stop
caring about growth and improvement
right somebody asked me about
satisfaction and happiness and they said
i'm i'm always always happy but i'm
almost never satisfied
i always want to be getting better to
grow to improve and it's more personal
thing of i want to put my best effort
out there
today this video i want to be one of my
best videos ever and maybe accomplish
that maybe i don't but it's the intent
because i'm never satisfied with where
i'm at but i'm happy
i'm happy as a human because by putting
out great work and by paying attention
to who you are serving i think that's
the key to to being happy to being
fulfilled to feeling like what you do
matters so it gives you that by focusing
who you are serving it gives you that
and number two
when you focus on the people who you are
serving here's a secret they take you to
the people who you're not serving yet
right
if you love this video you might share
it with somebody
you might come back and watch another
video and maybe you share that video
with somebody
when you focus on loving on your
community it's that it's a double whammy
in a positive way of you feel so good
that what you do is having a meaningful
effect
and when you love on your customers when
you love on your audience
they're going to take you to more people
because they're going to feel the love
and they're going to spread it for you
you don't have to tell them to do it
they'll do it on their own
because
they get good vibes by being around you
even if it's just virtually
like it's really critical
people really struggle with mental
health
in creation right now in
entrepreneurship right now it's a giant
struggle and i see a lot of my
contemporaries a lot of people
on youtube giving up after a couple
months saying i need a mental health
break i'm burnt out
and
i've made 12 000 videos over 12 years
and we're still going
and it's not again that i'm super human
it's just a shift
i'm i'm focusing on who i am serving and
who i am helping not all the things that
i suck at and how i'm not growing fast
enough because that game never ends
right
it's a never-ending climb
so some years i do better than others
and some months i do better than others
and do i want to have bigger numbers of
course
but it's not the reason why i do what i
do
one other little trick that helps a lot
is
assume that for somebody
at least one person
what you're going to create today is
going to be life
changing assume that for somebody at
least one person what you will create
today will be life-changing that if
you're making content and 100 people see
your video and you might think that's a
failure because you're used to a
thousand views on your video
that for one of those hundred people
it's a life-changing video
my hope my intention is that this video
today is a life-changing video for
somebody for for some of you watching
for most you watching maybe it's just
another good video like hey thank you
good good shot of espresso in the
morning here we go thank you awesome or
you're having breakfast or you're doing
something else you're driving in your
car and your way to work and you're
you're listening to me awesome amazing
but i hope
that for one person it's it's a
life-changing video it's finally going
to give you the permission to go off and
do the thing that you
desperately want to do that you know is
in your heart and has to come out i i
just feel that and i've seen it enough
over the years
of people telling me
that my videos have had an impact on
them
only years later yesterday at um brandon
burchard's influencer event that i spoke
at
people were commenting and then dming me
on instagram and sharing stories of i've
been following you since whatever year
and this is the first time they're ever
telling me
right they never left a comment on a
video they never messaged me they never
emailed me they never they never tweeted
they never sent anything it's the first
time i've ever seen their name ever and
they've been a hardcore follower for a
decade
and i've had a huge impact and i'm part
of their daily life and it's only now a
decade later that i'm finding out about
it
right
there are people who are like that for
you too
and we just assume that we don't matter
and we assume because
you might get a few less views on a
video or post that it's not having an
impact and not having a reach and then
you take that person and feel like you
suck assume that it's making an impact
on somebody
assume that it's life-changing for
somebody that you are giving hope
encouragement motivation permission for
somebody else to go and become their
best selves
when you tie your self-worth to the
results that you're getting
you ultimately are going to lose
because
you have some days where you don't get
results
and it's going to defeat you it's going
to lead to stress it's going to lead to
anxiety it's going to lead to wanting to
quit it's going to lead to burnout
the key to fulfillment the key to
momentum the key to sustained activity
and the key to actually loving the work
that you're doing
is reminding yourself
to focus on the people that you are
serving
instead of the ones that you aren't
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see 10
amazing rules from gabby bernstein check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there and appreciation
creates more of what you want so if
you've got something good going on go
appreciate it even more talk about it
thrive in it write about it feel it
meditate on the feeling of it